At Walmart, Target
and other fine stores.
>> Trace: ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
RULES OF THEE NOT ME.
THERE WAS A TEAM TO DEMOCRAT
FOR DEMOCRATS IN GEORGIA BEFORE
MEMBERS SIGNED A PETITION
DEMANDING L.A. COUNTY IMPOSE A
STRICT STAY AT HOME ORDER AFTER
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
RESPONSE COORDINATOR DR. BIRX
CAME UNDER FIRE AFTER TAKING A
TRIP TO VISIT FAMILY AFTER
ADVISING FAMILIES TO STAY HOME.
SHE JUST ANNOUNCED HER
RETIREMENT.
PETE HEGSETH JOINS US NOW.
IT IS ALWAYS GREAT TO SEE YOU.
DR. BIRX SAID THE FOLLOWING
QUOTING HERE.
I WILL HAVE TO SAY THIS
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN A BIT
OVERWHELMING.
IT HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT ON
MY FAMILY.
I THINK WHAT WAS DONE IN THE
LAST WEEK TO MY FAMILY, THESE
ARE ALL VERY DIFFICULT THINGS.
LOOK, I THINK SHE HAS DONE
YEOMAN’S WORK OVER THE PAST
NINE MONTHS BUT SHE IS ONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HELPED IMPLEMENT
THESE STRICT LOCKDOWNS.
YOU CAN’T PUSH FOR SOMETHING
AND THEN VIOLATE THEM AND
COMPLAIN BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
BEING MEAN TO YOU BECAUSE YOU
VIOLATED THEM.
>> THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT, TRACE.
I THINK HER STATEMENT AND HER
ACTIONS ARE VERY, VERY
REVEALING.
THE WAY A LOT OF OUR LEADERS.
SHE IS ONE OF OUR TOP
INFECTIOUS DISEASE -- SHE IS ON
THE COVID-19 TASK FORCE AND
KNOWS EVERY ASPECT AND ANGLE
AND PIECE OF INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY, SHE
STILL DEFAULTS BACK TO I’M A
FREE AMERICAN WHO -- IN THE
BACK OF WHEN HER MIND.
SHE MAY NOT SAY THAT.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE MY OWN
PERSONAL CHOICES WITH MY FAMILY
AT THIS MOMENT AFTER A
DIFFICULT YEAR BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND THE RISK THRESHOLD.
THE OTHER MEETING WITH ME
UNDERSTAND THAT AND ARE FREE
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN MAKE THEIR
OWN COMMON SENSE CHOICES.
IN THIS CASE SHE WAS CHARGED
WITH TELLING EVERYBODY WHAT TO
DO.
THEN MADE HER OWN PERSONAL
DECISION, WHICH IS A REMINDER
TO ALL OF US WHEN WE FEEL LIKE
A LOT OF THESE LOCKDOWN
MEASURES ARE ON OROUS WE’RE NOT
CRAZY.
WE CAN MAKE CHOICES FOR
OURSELVES TO MAKE THOSE WE LOVE
SAFE AND RESPONSIBLE AT THESE
MOMENTS.
NOT A LOT OF EMPATHY FOR ANY
CRITICISM SHE HAS RECEIVED
CONSIDERING HOW MANY OTHER
PEOPLE SHE TOLD NOT TO TRAVEL.
>> SHE WAS NOT CELEBRATING
THANKSGIVING.
SHE WAS WINTERIZING.
THE WASHINGTON TIMES WRITER
WRITES THE FOLLOWING.
DR. DEBRA BIRX CITES
THANKSGIVING BACKLASH.
IT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT ON MY
FAMILY AND VERY DIFFICULT FOR
AMERICANS WHO DON’T OWN
VACATION HOMES TO EXPERIENCE A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES THAN
LAWMAKERS, HEALTH OFFICIALS,
ETC.
AND THE REASON, PETE, THAT
NOBODY IS REALLY ABIDING BY THE
STAY AT HOME ORDERS.
PEOPLE AREN’T STAYING HOME.
THEY AREN’T ABIDING BY IT
BECAUSE THEY DON’T TRUST THE
BUREAUCRATS AND POLITICIANS WHO
ARE IMPLEMENTING THESE THINGS.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
AND THEN THEY LOOK AT DATA THAT
COMES OUT AS WE’RE TOLD TO
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE AND THEY SAY
WELL, YOU ARE LOCKING DOWN MY
RESTAURANTS AND THE HOUSES OF
WORSHIP AND PLACES WHERE I KNOW
THE DATA SHOWS COVID-19 IS NOT
SPREADING AND YOU ARE CRUSHING
MY FRIENDS AND THEIR BUSINESSES
AND OUR COMMUNITIES IN THE
PROCESS.
THOSE DOUBLE STANDARDS WILL NOT
HOLD.
OUR LEADERS CAN SAY THE COUNTRY
IS CLOSED BUT IF THE PEOPLE SAY
IT’S OPEN THROUGH THEIR OWN
COMMON SENSE THEN IT PRETTY
SOON IT IS OPEN AGAIN ONE WAY
OR ANOTHER AND IN FREE STATES
WHERE BUSINESSES ARE ALLOWED TO
OPEN RESPONSIBLY, LIFE LOOKS A
LOT DIFFERENT THAN LOCKDOWN
LAND.
GO TO TEXAS, FLORIDA, OTHER
PLACES WHERE THEY ARE MANAGING
TO LIVE THROUGH THIS.
THERE IS A WAY TO DO IT.
PEOPLE HAVE FINALLY SEEN THAT
AND THE REST OF US DON’T HAVE A
CHANCE TO WINTERIZE, TRACE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
A FANCY WORD FOR GETTING THE
WINTER OUT OF YOUR SYSTEM.
I DON’T KNOW.
SHE WILL DESERVE THIS CRITICISM.
>> Trace: IT MEANS NO TURKEY.
EVERYTHING IS THE SAME, NO
TURKEY ALLOWED AT WINTERIZING
WITH THE FAMILY.
THE OTHER SOURCE OF HYPOCRISY.
LOS ANGELES HOSPITALITY UNION
ADVOCATE FOR HOSPITALITY AND
HOTEL AND FOOD WORKERS.
THEY SIGNED THIS PETITION
CALLING FOR A STRICTER STAY AT
HOME ORDER IN CALIFORNIA TO GO
ON FOUR WEEKS AND DECIDED TO
FLY TO GEORGIA AND, YOU KNOW,
CAMPAIGN IN THE SENATE RUNOFF
TWEETING FOLLOWING HERE OUR
FIELD TEAM IS READY TO WARNOCK
OUR OSSOFF AND TAKE BACK THE
SENATE.
YOU GET THE INNUENDO THERE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT FINAL BIT OF
HYPOCRISY THERE.
>> THIS UNION WOULD BELIEVE
THAT THEIR BUSINESS OF
PERPETUATING UNION INTERESTS IS
ESSENTIAL.
IT IS THAT NO NON-ESSENTIAL
TRAVEL SHOULD BE ALLOWED.
OF COURSE THEY WOULD CARVE
THEMSELVES OUT AND LIVE IN A
WORLDVIEW WHERE PERPETUATING
THEIR OWN ABILITY TO SIT AT THE
POLITICAL TABLE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THEM.
THEY WILL ALWAYS FIND AN
INTERNAL REASON TO JUSTIFY
RAMPANT HYPOCRISY.
TO DO ONE TWEET ON DECEMBER
15th AND THEN THE NEXT ONE ON
DECEMBER 16th EITHER THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE RUNNING THE
TWITTER FEED OR THEY ARE FLYING
WITH THAT.
EVERYBODY STAY HOME BUT WE’LL
GO ADVANCE THE INTERESTS OF
DEMOCRATS ON BEHALF OF YOU AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT THIS IS.
UNIONS WILL STOP AT NOTHING TO
ADVANCE THEIR POWER.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THAT.
>> Trace: IT WOULD BE A GOOD
CHRISTMAS GIFT TO BUY MODERN